buenos dias santiago dos días oyentes es
casi seguro que si el pleno va a
reunirse porque la procuradoría general
de la república hizo la solicitud o está
lista para hacer la solicitud para que
debe revisar la posición del rey aquí
pero todos los especialistas sobre la
actitud del supremo dicen que el supremo
va a confirmar esta decisión democrática
el ministro fue aquí si enseñarse en
tiempos que significa para el pp el
partido de lula da silva el regreso el
posible regreso de lula da silva la
escena política dado el contexto en el
que se encuentra brasil en donde está el
gobierno de bolsonaro donde hay una
crisis económica y donde está la crisis
sanitaria de la pandemia del cob y 19
para jesulín yo podría decir que
bolsonaro nació con el rechazo al pp y
anula y ahora vuelve a el renacimiento
de las cenizas de lula y del pp con el
rechazo a bolsonaro jose hay una
dialéctica santiago entre los dos los
dos hombres y seguramente a esto la
decisión que se tomó es un sismo
político porque hasta ahora no había
ningún candidato que podría tener alguna
posibilidad de victoria frente a
versionar en 2022
por ahora lula es casi seguro que se me
ocurre se verá como candidato y muy
probablemente va a volver a la
presidencia de brasil porque esta
decisión en este momento cuando estamos
prácticamente a un año de que finalice
la presidencia de bolsonaro esto tendría
intenciones políticas dado que las
elecciones están solamente a la vuelta
de la esquina que piensa usted
yo creo que hay un juego dialéctico
entre política y derecho hay muchos
jueces que hacen política y hay muchos
políticos que hacen
[Música]
justicia que hace cosas de derecho no la
la frontera entre los dos es muy muy
débil yo desde dirige como los animales
cuando son incubados con una enfermedad
conmovidos reaccionó con autodefensas
los buses guard los cuerpos sociales
también reacción
y esto como una reacción del cuerpo
social brasilero
la decisión de fakih pérez es muy
aceptada y brasil hay la idea sabían que
se puede perder los anillos pero no se
puede perder los dedos lo que de que se
resume muy bien esa situación de
inversión de valores y de aceptar que la
lucha contra la corrupción es limitada
que salsa no va más adelante se va a
dejar el salado porque porque tenemos un
otro adversario mucho más fuerte mucho
más importante mucho más peligroso y el
gobierno de brasil y por esto que hago
esta relación entre enfermedad en ser
vacuna y política